[Aplausos]
[Música]
eres consciente que nuestra expectativa
de vida acaba de los 3 en 5 años
viviremos 5 años menos de lo que
deberíamos
soy Mayra flores y solía ser una
científica
me lo doy aquí en eso me velocidad y se
la de bachillerato en química me laven
la Facultad de Ciencias viaje España y
semi maestría y doctorado me lavé con
honores según mi directora publique en
revistas científicas
en el 2018 decidí colgar el mandil de
laboratorio y dedicarme hasta lo que en
ese momento solamente había sido mi
hobby y pasatiempo y Carmen tiempo
completo a la divulgación de la ciencia
a contar lo que hacen los científicos a
contar porque la ciencia es necesaria
con la esperanza que repente pudiera
también educar mínimamente y algunos
conceptos científicos
creo prefiero profundamente que
necesitamos aumentar la cultura
científica de la población peruana y
ahora con mucha urgencia la de la limeña
ven esta fotografía aquí
pues es una fotografía de llima que
normalmente está bueno si se anima panza
de burro normalmente está un poco gris
pero últimamente también es porque está
muy contaminado
tenemos un horrible problema no sé si lo
ha notado no sé si se han enterado
hace unas semanas un informe de la
Universidad de Chicago que mide la
calidad del aire a nivel mundial
determinó que rima nuestra Lima la
capital del Perú estaba es la más
contaminada de Latinoamérica
y no se ha pasado por un poquito ese
nivel se ha pasado por casi el doble
casi el doble de los límites máximos que
normalmente recomienda la conexión
Mundial de la Salud para decir que son
los límites permisibles para la salud
humana
sabías ese dato te habías puesto a
pensar en ello
cuánto ustedes
allí que me están viendo ahora por el
facebook por el youtube tienen hijos
levante la mano por favor allí en casa
si levante la mano o tienen nietos o
tienen sobrinos
las caras de los niños
qué ciudades estamos heredando
si nosotros ya como adultos más perdido
5 años de vida ellos cuántos años de
vida van a perder se ha ido a cuántos
años vas a reducir y os van a fallecer
mucho más jóvenes de lo que nosotros lo
haremos
no hemos sido conscientes de que tenemos
acciones que repente están influyendo en
la calidad del aire de todos
nos han dado cuenta de pronto que han
empezado a aparecer alergias
o de repente
personas para algunas afecciones en las
vías respiratorias
no se preocupen tranquilos tranquilos
que ya les toca en breve les va a tocar
a todos nos va tocar probablemente
quiero que vean este cuadro que es de
las causas de muerte en Lima en
porcentajes
estás barritas
sobre todo las últimas dos de abajo esas
dos rojas no sé si llegan a leer espero
que llegan muy bien allí en sus
pantallas
pero son infecciones respiratorias
agudas bajas o sea que tiene que ver con
los pulmones en la primera causa
la segunda enfermedad pulmonar
yo en doctorado ise química no hice no
hice medicina pero
no tendrá algo que ver no tengo que ver
con la contaminación que está teniendo
en esta ciudad y con que haya tantas
causas de muerte no lo sé
curios una curiosa coincidencia no lo
creen
nosotros normalmente pues que nos vende
la televisión que hay asesinatos con
esta ciudad es insegura sí por supuesto
que sí
hay accidentes de tránsito
pero han visto
ven aquí qué porcentaje realmente
significan esas muertes deberíamos
preocuparnos tanto por ellas o porque no
en una causas de muerte es que no nos
estamos dando cuenta pero de repente
deben tener más atención no cree
y qué podemos hacer
hay acciones muy simples no desplazarse
en bicicleta que más te ayuda a perder
un poco de peso a compartir el adulto en
fin hay muchas cuestiones que podemos
hacer uno tranquilo no vengo o ir a
concientizarte no vengo a regañar te de
todas las cosas que no has hecho pero
que podrías estar haciendo mejor no
tranquilo ese no es mi misión por hoy
otro día será
otro día te buscaré te encontraré y te
concientizar eh
pero no hoy
hoy quiero contarte
o no sé si llegan a ver pero bueno guapa
una historia que nació en el CERN
laboratorio europeo de física de
partículas
en el año
2012 este laboratorio se hizo público o
mejor dicho se volvió un poco famoso en
los medios en la prensa usualmente que
no habla de ciencia pero ese día lo hizo
en el 2012 porque
por qué se descubrió la aguja en el
pajar que andaban buscando todos los
científicos que trabajan ahí en Ginebra
Suiza cerca de la frontera con Francia
que encontraron encontraron el bosón de
Higgs
pero con el perdón de los físicos
posiblemente le cené la partícula de
Dios no
se le puso ese nombre porque bueno ese
no ese nombre que le puso un poco la
prensa pero qué significa el bosón de
Higgs fue esa rompecabeza es aguja en el
pajar que era la última pieza para el
modelo estándar de la física de
partículas
modelo que explica muchas cosas no
muchas cosas a día de hoy tranquilo
tampoco voy a empezar a una cátedra de
física de partículas
sinceramente yo tampoco lo entiendo muy
bien tengo amigos que si lo entienden y
hay que creer yo digo que así es una
acción de fer creadas por qué son
partículas que quizás no vemos pero
bueno ya la detectan y ya se estudia muy
bien
pero qué pasó porque eres hablo del Seat
por qué en el año
trabajaba por allí este señor
timberly no sé si lo conocen si alguna
vez he escuchado su nombre yo sabía lo
que había hecho pero soy sincera tuve
que Google Earth su nombre para en la
wikipedia para esta charla porque no
recordaba exactamente su nombre pero si
su trabajo
eres del año noventa alfinal es que hizo
el por supuesto con un grupo de
investigadores eres investigador
computación científica pero con un grupo
de físicos de programadores sucesos en
que la ciencia siempre es
multidisciplinaria no no trabaja uno
solo pero él fue el líder y qué es lo
que hizo team
es lo que hizo fue poner el primer
servidor Web servidor web y la primera
página web
qué quiere decir eso que él pues puso en
marcha lo que ahora nos permite
conectarnos estoy yo aquí en el Teatro
de la UNI se están en el facebook en el
youtube en sus casas en el trabajo de
repente en el microondas de varios
sitios que me están escuchando
y qué es lo que hizo pues en Internet
es Internet ha sido una herramienta
poderosísima sobre todo ahora en la
pandemia no es cierto cuando estamos
cuando estuvimos en cuarentena
yo recuerdo que es 16 de marzo del año
pasado
cuando de pronto no podía creer que nos
encerraban a todos en nuestra casa y era
como
no puede ser estoy viviendo una novela
de mis favoritas el sol desnudo le han
leído disagas imoveis magnífica saber si
vamos un gran divulgador cientifico y
también hace muchas novelas de ficción y
de qué trata el sol desnudo pues es un
planeta donde solo viven 20000
habitantes y cada persona vive solo en
su casa y con asistencia de robots no
hay contacto con otros humanos
cuando hay reuniones se reúne por
holograma todos ellos no cada uno seguro
en su casa y la reuniones virtual a base
hologramas y por qué porque no se reúnen
si es bonito estar con otras personas el
mismo lugar y conversar con ellos
porque tiene miedo de contagiarse de
respirar el mismo aire que otra persona
y le puede contagiar algún
microorganismo como un virus
persona conocido esa 900 ficción en ese
momento ya no me era tan lejana dije que
está pasando estoy viviendo mi novela
favorita
al inicio pues quizás lo tomamos un poco
como vacaciones un poco no sabíamos que
teníamos que hacer Sila trabajo mi
trabajo estudiar o no sabíamos que hacer
y
pero pasan los días y vamos viendo que
eran esta Navidad no podíamos salir a
conversar no podíamos ver a nuestros
familiares nuestros amigos
pero pues de pronto empezamos a aprender
a usar el zoom Smith decente vamos a ir
Sky que ya existía para poder poder
comunicarnos verdad entonces pues
realmente en Internet ha sido una
herramienta muy útil en esta época de
pandemia
y no solamente puedes con la gente de
nuestro de nuestro alrededor de nuestro
país nuestra ciudad sino con gente de
cualquier parte del mundo
lo
importante también hola interesante es
que ya no dependemos solamente de las
computadoras
puede ser elemento caro
lo importante y lo chévere aquí es que
desde un celular un celular un aparato
que antes era solo para llamar ahora es
realmente una computadora que tenemos en
nuestra mano
alguna vez han puesto a pensar la
cantidad de trabajo por detrás para que
tú tengas tu celular te invito a que
levanten se celebra en este momento y
veas es un aparato pequeño bueno no sé
mucho pero bueno normalmente la mayoría
de normales tenemos más o menos molesto
no un smartphone que nos permite hacer
casi lo mismo que la computadora
conectarnos a Internet con él está más
por el 1000 por el zoom el facebook el
youtube
detrás de ese celular hay trabajo de
muchos matemáticos físicos químicos
ingenieros hay trabajo de muchísimo
científico te habías puesto a pensar eso
no verdad o quizá si
te lo dejo de tarea
porque quiero contarte una última
historia
y esa es la Edward Jenner dime que sí
que son este nombre por favor
espero que sí pero seguro que no
qué pasó con Edward Jenner
pues se dice que este hombre el trabajo
este hombre ha salvado a mayor cantidad
de personas que el trabajo de cualquier
otra persona en el mundo en todas las
historias
y que hizo de ballenas
emoji era un médico que vivía por 1700
un poco por esos años y 1749
se dio cuenta que era lecheras las
mujeres porteña van las vacas no se
contagiaban con la viruela que era una
epidemia que asolaba a esa a la
población en aquellos años
pues como todos científico curioso hijo
de repente algo tiene que ver porque
ellas están en contacto con las vacas
que las vacas sufren también la viruela
y porque ellas no se contagian entonces
que hizo como todo investigador
científico hizo un experimento no agarró
un poquito de la Cruz de esas ya las
pesan que la viruela le salía una llagas
luego tiene costras por supuesto tragar
un poquito de pus
inyecto afine un niño que era el hijo de
su jardinero
bueno la parece poca la parte ética como
que todavía no está muy avanzada no
experimentar con niños pero bueno eso
estoy enfermo
obviamente así depresión enfermedad lo
cuidaron muy bien no falleció
y meses después volvió a hacer un
experimento de inyector nuevamente un
poquito de la pus de las costras de otra
persona enferma con viruela y no se
enfermo
qué hizo Jenner
aplicó la primera vacuna
hubieron algunos
experimentos antes que hicieron esto
también pero esos experimentos no
ayudaron a comprender el Real la real
importancia de lo que estaban viendo
pues el que realmente
estudio en detalle la vacuna y el que la
hizo conocida
la viruela en el siglo
20 en si no te acaba de pasar no hace
boca de poquito hace 21 años
se llevó 500 millones de personas a
nivel mundial
solamente necesito no estamos contando
desde los inicios desde cuándo Jenner
estaba
fue la pandemia y epidemia que más
personas se ha llevado
pero también gracias a la vacuna de
Jenner a día de hoy de viruela es la
única enfermedad realmente erradicada en
esos planetas y hemos terminado con esta
enfermedad hay muchas que están a
nuestro nuestro planeta como la que
tenemos ahora El Hobbit pero ya tenemos
un problema menos y eso fue gracias
ayer
creamos no la vacuna algunos se han
vacunado ya se va con anestesia se
vacunaron tú tú estás vacunado ya no
verdad o no crean o no era vacuna
posiblemente esta no es una herramienta
perfecta por supuesto si alguna gente de
repente de cayó mal sí pero el
porcentaje es mínimo es mucho más
beneficio lo que trae una vacuna que el
que no vacunarse y esta es una de las
primeras curvas que mostraban esas
actividad la línea morada muestra la
mortalidad de los médicos los médicos
peruanos no lo que están en primera
línea como estaban cuidando
even cómo cae cómo cae esa cola qué
quiere decir que la vacuna está
funcionando nos está protegiendo quizás
no evita que nos contagiamos bueno
seguimos contagiando pero no está
muriendo ya la gente en tanta proporción
como le estaba haciendo el inicio de la
pandemia
fusionando vale quizás la vacuna está de
repente entre sinopharm o falsedad que
te haya tocado / 93 95% vale la pena
Tomares viejos no porque no
ya sea que te impacto el inicio de mi
Txarrak sabiendo de que realmente
estamos perdiendo calidad de vida y
expectativas de vida estamos viendo
menos porque nos traiga está muy
contaminado ya sea que quieras
empezar a hacer algo por es por prevenir
empezar a disminuir la
factores que contaminan nuestro aire
ya sea que uses Ono Internet
la María y nosotros ya nos hemos vuelto
casi dependientes internet si bien es
cierto nuestro país todavía hay lugares
donde no llega pero es cuestión de
tiempo que llegue y cada vez dependemos
más en Internet nos da muchas
facilidades
ya sea que creas o no era vacuna pero
las cifras no mienten estamos ayudando a
solucionar un problema
ya sea cual sea tu situación te invito a
que te hagas esta pregunta
necesito ciencia en mi vida
[Aplausos]